i could see my legs are gone most of my
arm
was mangled this this hand wasn't
working either and i just assumed those
were gonna be the last moments of my
life
i just thought you know i'll be dead
soon
[Music]
i was working in afghanistan i was there
again looking at the impact of the war
on civilians
you know we we see a lot about the
impact of war
on on our soldiers and the u.s soldiers
fighting there but we see very little
about what happens to the civilians
and i wanted to tell that story as part
of that story i was embedded with a
group of american soldiers
and you know and dealing with dealing
with that and unfortunately one day
we're on patrol
we got ambushed um we'd been kind of
under fire for a few days
in that particular area it was quite hot
and as we were heading for cover i
triggered an ied
and it's the weirdest loneliest
experience you could imagine i mean i
stepped on the id
i didn't lose my consciousness i
remember flying through the air landing
on my
my back i could see my legs are gone
most of my arm was mangled this this
hand wasn't working either
and i just assumed those were going to
be the last moments of my life i just
thought
you know i'd be dead soon what followed
was was harder than the
initial injury i spent 46 days in
intensive care
and then three months after i got
injured um i was well enough for the
first time
to be moved into a chair to have a
shower
and when they put me in this wheelchair
and took me to have a shower it was the
first time i'd seen myself in a mirror
and i was disgusted it was like
everything suddenly
hit me you know i could see my legs
missing scars across my body
at that time i had a colostomy bag it
was just devastating and
when they put me back into bed it took
four people to carry me just
to move me even into the bed i was
completely utterly
helpless and i cried myself to sleep and
i remember thinking
i wish i'd just died on the helicopter i
wasn't brave enough or strong enough to
deal with
this new reality but the next morning
um i'm kind of notoriously stubborn and
something had
triggered back in my mind and i said to
myself from this moment on i would never
think about the things
i can't do but i will focus on what i
can and i will excel at those things
you know i have more fun now with the
people i photographed and i ever have
because i think there was always a sense
of if i was photographing somebody in
horrific situation
you know i was the guy that could just
get on a plane and go home and i could
be there for all the right reasons
but the dynamic was always different now
you know people are looking at me they
know i've gone through the same thing as
them
so normally what happens is we take
photographs but then we eat together we
have drinks together we laugh we dance
and i probably celebrate life more now
with the people i photograph than i felt
i could have
or had the opportunity before i got
injured
i had always seen war as this kind of
cool glamorous amazing thing
war is about trying to kill trying to
maim and if you're not maimed or killed
you do it the other person
and there are times when you're under
fire and you've got a camera and you're
lying in a ditch and you think what am i
doing here and
um you're trying to load a roll of a
film for the first time
when somebody's firing a gun above you
is is is scary
yeah am i in danger at times of course
but the people that live there they're
in peril every day
you know i think that the hardest story
for me ever was um covering the fighting
in mosul a few years ago um when the the
city was was
in the grips of a conflict between isis
and the iraqi government who are trying
to retake the city
and i had never seen devastation like
that
you know this was a great metropolis a
really modern city
and it was pulverized by both sides and
just families devastated you know you'd
meet one person and their whole family
had died
you'd meet children who'd lost all their
limbs and actually it was there was a
young
kid called darwood and darwin had lost
his legs and his arm he'd been injured
like i had
and he was so resilient and and positive
and
every time i passed him he'd always
smile look at me and i chat to his
mother
and after a few days it was actually his
mother said to me you know why are you
not taking photographs
i could take a photograph of somebody's
suffering i could take a photograph of
this child
injured but whatever photograph i took
that day
tomorrow more we're gonna die more we're
gonna be
injured and she looked at me and she was
kind of stern
and she pointed it downward and she said
when a child is injured like this
the whole world should see it and it
kind of snapped me back
into doing my job
i was described the stories as like
little scars every single story affects
you and and takes you home yeah one
story that that probably is the most
important story to me is
of a woman called hollud uh hulud had
been at home in syria
during the civil war there and a sniper
shot her in the neck
she was actually in the garden tending
to some vegetables and she fell on one
of her children
she got emergency treatment and then
they took her to lebanon to the bekhar
valley where i met her
if you imagine a woman a tetraplegic
woman paralyzed from the neck down
lying in a makeshift tent she had no
medical support apart from her husband
jamal who was her full-time carer
anyway i photographed her and her
husband
and this was soon after my own injury
and so i was just coming back
returning to work so it was a really
important story for me i came back and
the story was published
kind of appeared around the world and
and i must admit
i kind of moved on from it and then a
couple of years later i was back in
lebanon and i tracked down some of the
families that i'd met
before including khalood and and jamal
and i remember that phone call so
clearly to this day um
it was jamal and said over here you're
back in lebanon we'd like to see you
and i said well where are you and he
said we're in the same place you last
saw us
and stupidly i hadn't even thought to
look for them there i just assumed there
was no
way that this woman could still be
living in that same shitty situation
surely the whole point of what i do is
it changes somebody's life it does
something
can you imagine this tiny little room
there's no windows in the two years
since i've seen her she had not moved
from that bed just staring at the same
bit of ceiling
and yet it's a place full of love and
laughter and happiness and the kids are
always laughing and
joking and the husband jamal when we go
to the little kitchen on the side he
always whispers to me his greatest fear
is that she doesn't love him as much as
he loves her
but khalood is like a she's like an
angel she just smiled and she's like
look we knew you'd come back it's fine
and i thought well all i can do is is
focus on on doing my job better this
time so i spent the next week
documenting their daily life and i like
to take photographs back with me so that
i can i can share
the way that i've represented people and
on the last day before i left i was
thinking should i give this photograph
back to
cloud and jamal that i'd taken two years
before because nothing had changed
literally the same photograph was in
front of me but i thought now i have to
and i handed this photograph
to khalood but before i did i said to
her when i took this photograph
i did not take a photograph of a refugee
i did not take a photograph of a
disabled woman when i took this
photograph i took a photograph of a
couple who are so
in love with each other and actually
this is a photograph of love
because she made me realize i'm not a
war photographer
i document love you will never see a
photograph i take of a gun
of violence or any act like that what i
photograph
is those moments of intimacies a
grandmother brushing granddaughter's
hair
father on the ground doing maths with
his kids a couple
like khalid and jamal holding hands and
what i find in the worst places in the
world
is incredible humanity and i find love
you know somebody asked me once do you
think you can change the world with your
photographs
and i said no but maybe i can inspire
the person that can
[Music]
you